Now you are an NBA champion, Nikola.
How does that feel? It's good. It's good.
The job is done.
We can go home now. Congratulations.
said after the Lakers win
you said you were surprised
that you didn't feel more so.
I'm curious what you are feeling right now
and if you're looking forward
to a parade coming up in Denver,
When is parade.
Thursday.
No, I need to go home.
Okay.
parade coming up here on Thursday. Yes.
How soon ‘til you're back in Sombor.
Sunday's I have my horse racing.
Horse racing.
I was going to get to that, the horse
racing that
maybe I don't know how.
We arrived Thursday parade.
Friday, maybe. Would you make it?
I don't know. Maybe.
Maybe you got enough time
to squeeze it in.
I'm going to ask Josh to give me a give me
give me a plane Oh, I think.
I think.
I think he'll definitely let you
get the team plane You deserve that.
You deserve a little bit more.
I did it on TV.
I'm going to finish by.
I put him under the pressure.
Yes, I did, but I don't feel bad at all.
help us win the championship.
Well, I'm.
I'm burping, sorry.
Nikola, The dinner you guys had at Jeff
Green's house was very well documented.
To what extent is tonight's victory
a psychological victory,
and to what extent is that a result
of great team building like that dinner?
He has a nice house.
And when you look at the future,
what is this capable of
propelling you guys?
Because I think you had the starting
five locked down
for maybe the next couple of years.
I didn't know that. That's great.
But to be honest,
I don't think about the next year.
I'm going to ask the coach
to give me a couple of week,
a couple of weeks more off so I can
I can be ready for the season.
That's supposed to be a joke.
And you didn’t laugh,
that's good job guys.
You are the first person in NBA history
to have a 30,
20, 10 NBA Finals game.
What does that mean to you?
I mean, to be honest, not much.
I figured you were going to say that.
The fourth player in NBA Finals history
to record the line that you had today
joining LeBron, K.D.
and Tim Duncan.
What do you what do you think about
when you hear that?
It's not a big 23, 12
and four fourth ever the 23,
ten and four oh.
I mean, I don't know.
Nice. It's a good
I mean, I don't know what to say.
Do you have the stats.
Your country can make history
in the next few days.
We know that Djokovic winning his 23rd
Grand slam
and you with your first NBA championship,
what does it mean for Serbia?
Oh, yes, of course.
Actually, he texted me for real.
Yes, he texted me. Yes.
Yes, he texted me for real.
He didn't lie. Novak
just won the French Open.
You just won the finals, MVP
and the championship.
Is this the greatest era of Serbian
athletes?
Gotta be.
I congratulation.
I'm going to see if he texted me you know,
I don't know.
I mean, oh. for
how many texts you have?
A lot.
So, no, I'm not going to I'm going
to turn off the phone.
growing up overseas,
like who were the guys that you wanted
to pattern your game after?
Because we really haven't
seen a big in the game quite like you.
I think it's Shaq.
Thank you, brother.
Appreciate that.
there is a bunch of things that
that I like that I like to do.
I mean, probably that's a that's a normal
thing, you know, Nobody likes his job.
Or maybe they do.
They're lying. Champions Trophy.
On behalf of the Denver
Nuggets, head coach
Michael Malone.
do you ever give a speech today
or during the playoffs?
Do you ever speak to the team
like a locker room speech? Hmm.
I mean, no.
I mean,
I just wanted to make fun
at least a little bit,
you know, And I was hoping he's
going to pay my fine.
But no.
Nikola, Michael Malone said that you were
coaching them up in the fourth quarter,
kind of.
He gave you credit for saying,
let's go to the two man game.
What is Coach Jokic like?
I don't know.
I don't want to be a coach.
I think that's the worst job on the planet
for sure.
how have you grown
and what have you learned from being a dad
and have you noticed any of those skills
translating to being a better
basketball player?
Nah, you know, that cannot help you.
Tonight.
Most triple doubles by a center.
Congratulations. Thank you.
Thank you.
There you go.
Where is Shaq in
that, Is Shaq in that list.
No, no, because I've never passed.
is it?
Is it possible to ask in Serbian?
Yeah.
Do you ask
if it’s possible to talk to Serbia.
Go ahead.
Just saying.
I think, you know, I know It’s
been really nice speaking.
Now it's my turn. Good job.
You want to?
I guess I'm gone y’all.
Give a round of applause for KCP.
Half minutes of this game
ten in the first quarter
after just eight in all of game four.
And you were wondering
if maybe this They weren't
playing at a high efficiency level early
on, front, right.
Are you drunk? Yes.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Thank you.
Though, uh, you know that I told that
I don't want to stay on parade,
but I fucking want to stay on parade.
This is the best
This is. This is amazing.
This is this.
We're all going to remember this
to our whole lives. And.
And then to see you guys
that came out on the streets.
And actually, this one is for you.
We love you Denver.
This one is for you. Thank you, guys.